yeah welcome to this video playing
dinner meet and I'm always forgetting
the name of the sky are two a God will
Gabrielle young I played a couple of
times before banco know the baloney yeah
i played this nigeria line on the very
early age five and interesting large III
is not great now okay but hard to play
without f3
Queen d2 hmm what a weird weird position
we had because he hasn't canceled yeah
this is one one interesting point of
this and then asking yourself is there
some way to punish a night be 5a 696 and
saying nonsense night b5 queen bee six
though Knight to c3 and threatening
night a form this is actually quite
dangerous night a four is the thread
winning the depot
or winning whatever but something I
think why is the Queen 86 if he castles
night a for Queen a six yeah maybe he
needs to actually allow that okay this
is another possibility f45 and for age
35 okay no no no use and spending much
more time so it's probably the right
move anyway laughs they will probably
lose material and must find find some
South Asian compean busy compensation
nergy 483 night age 65 verse is terrible
and night back to the seven night a 494
maybe this is playable 97 night a four
night if form but i have to add Queenie
to leave this this I thought just this
Andy five a six maybe you can play six
now no okay they just gave gave this way
if five is too much problem should be to
you know proficiently to
and 94 something i have got night c4
always lets you phone yeah it's still a
bit a bit a bit funky disposition some
chances to to muddy the waters for black
can I go here I'd like to yeah come on
taking the Queen and if I go III is
there some something 94 maybe it's also
not working I can maybe yeah but this is
not really really really I think if I
can just take the six here why not just
take the six of course to point x good
night Eve for but I have 98 I can just
take on Isis plug it anyway I take the
eight now what if i go i can take a look
actually 9040 force play more can eat it
and then i need to take okay and snow
hmm takes Queen check sir Sir as a
problem hmm ah what a sick game you
really managed to do to get into into
the position here yeah 93 now threatened
wait I can take you for no I cannot
let's not do 496 but it's not on
should have six maybe i'll have what the
crap have What nonsense
Oh
checkmate ah what a game yeah this is
always frustrating and blitz chess I
mean this is just a just peace for for
some awesome tricks but there are tricks
and I just fall for something it's
always frustrating with the comp + 6
here first take on d 696 and resins and
this is actually yeah demos I must take
f6 first I am such an idiot sometimes
it's just just completely out over I
mean what what what is there there is
nothing absolutely nothing like this and
and it's it's just just silly + 7 for
nothing ok let's briefly man this is
already winning for black unbelievable I
can still take f6 why on earth I didn't
calculate here really if I actually
thought I can always play this but he
can of course take me for yeah yeah well
his opening play was really atrocious
but what can you do if you don't win + 7
position alright thanks for watching